[Music]
okay 1360.
this time we're playing black e4 e5
knight c3 knight of three knight c6
and ponciani now we're on the black side
of the ponciani which i've been playing
with white
quite a bit and i'll teach you guys a
system that disarms
well
there's two
systems here that are excellent
i'll show you guys a system that i was
really afraid of facing when i played
the ponciani in the us championship and
that's the move d5 very thematic i mean
you strike in the center the whole point
is that after ed5 queen d5
85 25 the point is that the knight can't
come out to c3 and here
queen a4 is the main line
now most people play f6
most people play f6 but there is a
relatively little known gambit that's in
my opinion not only practically speaking
danger but objectively
is simply equalizing objectively
speaking and that is bishop d7
looks like it blunders the pawn it does
but you are preparing
to trade white's only developed piece on
f3
and acquire a massive lead in
development which is exacerbated by the
fact that white is a hard time getting
the knight on b1 out
of course where you can see that we are
setting up a discovery as our opponent
is thinking think about where the knight
wants to go after e takes d5 i gave a
big hint
yeah knight d4 is going to be the move
knight t4 the queen is going to have to
back down to d1
and then we we trade on f3
and quickly develop our king side yeah
knight d4
queen d1 i had f3
and impressed you know white's he's he's
finding the moves
okay so of course queen takes f3 g takes
f3 maybe is a move but that just seems a
little too brazen
yeah queen takes f3 and knight f6 so i'm
playing this very quickly but
i think this is relatively clear
and the point is that the queen is
supposed to be quite awkward on f3 it's
it's
vulnerable to all sorts of
these types of ideas
in fact e4 is
yeah maybe it has a name the caro gambit
i didn't know that
but it's it's been played i mean it's
probably been played over 100 times but
not nearly as popular as f6
d4
yeah so d4 is a good move when it opens
up the center prepares to develop
and again the the
emphasis here is on
active play development
so he takes d4 i'm sure is a pot is a
um is a possible move but
i like the movie four just keeping the
foot on the gas pedal here
e4 is
is more dynamic
and in some situations we even allow
white to play c4
that's okay because we're
again we're we're playing for
development here we're not necessarily
playing to win back the pawn
d1
91 yeah so now i'm out of book myself
um
many different
possibilities here
yeah again queen back to d1 let's think
for a second here this is an interesting
position
yeah well i think the simplest is now to
take the pawn the simplest is to take
the pawn
but um
we have kind of a cool positional move
here that we could make
we have a cool positional move that we
can make here
to kind of
try to take the pawn on our own terms
and that's the move
no that's sort of b5 actually this is a
common idea in this line b5 to prevent
c4 sort of carve out those light squares
but uh i don't
i don't want to experiment let's take
the pawn
let's just take the pawn
bishop g4 i don't like and why bishop g4
you're just hunting the queen but the
queen is going to reroute to b3 which is
where it wants to go anyway
bishop g4 is
uh is is very superficial
bishop c4 okay good fine
and again
we we should be accurate here
so multiple candidate moves we have to
decide on a higher level if we're going
to keep the knight on d5 multiple ways
to do that or are we going to drop it
back to b6
knight b6 is with tempo that's the
upside the downside is that our knight
is centralized so
i like to move c6 here as well
the question is do we want to keep the
knight there or is developing with tempo
more important
i mean hard to say
hard to say i i don't know
but i i feel like
i don't know
let's keep the knight on d5 let's go c6
let's try to
keep our pieces closer to the center
we also had bishop e6 here which maybe
was even stronger
sort of creating tension between the
bishops
so the next move is going to be bishop
d6 and then we're going to castle and in
some situations we're even going to give
up the e4 pawn
get rid of it
and aim for quick nope why am i
yeah
okay
so um castles
and now um
yeah c6 does open squares for the queen
yeah it also opens squares for the queen
potentially for sure
and bishop d6 get the bishop out
the bishop out
now i don't love queen c7 here
i don't love queen c7 here i i don't
like this battery right you want to have
the opposite battery with the queen in
front of the bishop
in general because queen c7 can just be
met with h3 rookie 1 excellent play by
white
how should we proceed
e4 pawn is vulnerable
we can castle here
we can absolutely cancel and kind of
play at marshall
marshall gambit style
but just because i said we might
sacrifice the pawn doesn't necessarily
mean we want to
and i don't see a point in sacking it i
think f5 is perfectly safe
this check is met with the g6
and then on the next move we're ready to
castle queen b3 xl another excellent
move by white
another excellent move by white but not
so dangerous now castles loses a piece
bishop takes d5 check takes queen takes
d5 check we're going to lose the bishop
on d6
so
we have to set our priorities right what
exactly is the threat
well there's two threats there's queen
takes b7 which i certainly don't want to
i don't want him capturing that pawn and
then we're going to have weaknesses
so in this situ i also don't want to
play knight p6 because then we're going
to have to deal with bishop f7 shot
so two things to realize the first is i
i mentioned that a move is bad
previously but right now the priority is
to defend not necessarily to get our
pieces onto the best squares this is a
very important concept
so i might have trashed this move a move
ago but now i like it a lot more there's
a good way to defend this pawn prepare
long castling
and also create a threat against h2
which is not the worst thing in the
world and now i think queen c7 makes
more sense
this is i think the the best that we can
do in this
given the set of circumstances
this is the best that we can do given
this set of circumstances
and then
we might very well cast along or we
might still castle short depending on
what he does
no i think black is better i think we're
very much in control of the game
yeah no this guy is this guy is uh is a
fighter for sure
no i don't know he's totally legit he's
but just playing well
if f3 we can just castle and his king's
gonna be wide open there
no no i don't think f5 was bad
i don't think this is uh allowing this
is bad for black
i mean look at the the space advantage
white's lack of queen side development
and just our pieces are all in this
nicely in the center we have a pawn
wedge we've got
lots of advantages in this position
and oh it's totally worth a relatively
meaningless middle game pawn
okay g3
fine
so now we have a decision to make we
have several decisions in fact we have
to decide whether we're sacrificing the
pawn on d5
if we are
then we have long castles and short
castles
but
again
when we talk about sacrifices
we should only sacrifice if it's
necessary if we have a perfectly good
way
if we have a perfectly good way to
defend the knight on d5 and not
sacrifice
then we should right and this is what
i'm the point i'm trying to make early
in the speedrun we can play bishop e6 in
order to play you know like tall play
like a sacrificial style you have to
learn
how to not sacrifice and win games in a
simple fashion first bishop e6 perfectly
watertight in fact b5 is now
potentially a possibility trying to
knock the bishop off of the
diagonal the move g3 has also created a
hook so in your mind you should
immediately be thinking of two ideas
the first is preparing f4 and blasting
through the diagonal the second is h5h4
this is a hook we want to exploit it the
purpose of the kingside attack
for a beginner says discarded or the
bishop is loose right so how do i know
that this is not going to be exploited
because of the pawn on e4 pawn is
defended i'm not worried about f3
because that move is way too weak in it
i'm not ready to play f4 yet because if
rook takes c4 we have to castle first
and then we'll be ready to play up four
it is i understand it's scary to make
the move and it should be scary you
should be hesitant to make this move
because you notice that
it walks sort of into the x-ray that's
not a bad thing that's a great thing
but as you move up to the intermediate
level
you should be able to make exceptions
you should be able to say all right this
is a little bit scary but i don't see
anything concrete so i'm going to go for
it
all right short castle why short castle
not long castle because this
kills two birds with one stone it puts
the rook on f8
which greatly intensifies the effect of
f4
got it
so f4 is is a massive massive threat now
this is
white is in tremendous trouble here i
just don't see a defense against it
and why what is the root cause of this
is the lack of development on the on the
queen side now he tries to develop as
quickly as possible it's too late
he's not going to make it happen
but we still don't really have to rush
with that four we don't have to rush
with it
we can
if we want we can play for in a better
version
yeah b5 looks amazing here the p5 looks
great
f4 bishop takes f4 is a little bit dicey
and let me explain why i don't like f4
f4 bishop takes f4
bishop takes f4 knight takes e4 i'll
show this on the board after the game
and you know he gets two pieces for the
two pawns for the piece and he maintains
the king side structure
so i would propose one of many moves we
can play king h8 you can play rook a8
bringing rooks into the game we can play
queen f7
but let's settle on the move b5 let's
get rid of this bishop that's going to
make it so much easier for us to play
for
hopefully that explanation makes sense
rook a8 is a lovely move as well very
patient get the rook into the center
and it's not like we're delaying right
we're playing a move with tempo
no h65 is too slow we don't need to play
h6 g5
we don't need to prepare f4 we've
already prepared it
why is b5 better now than one move ago
um
no it was perfectly it was great one
move ago two b5 here is a totally
legitimate move i would have considered
it
h5h4 it's not like it's too risky it's
just unnecessary right if we have we can
do the same thing
in one move and far more effectively
now don't be over attracted to the
discovery right we don't have any good
discoveries because if we do anything
with the knight we're going to drop the
bishop with check
so rook a8 here in that regard would be
a great move
but i think we're ready for f4 i think
we are
i think we're ready for f4 because the
point is if g takes up where we take
with a knight
and that allows us to defend the bishop
simultaneously
and that's going to be crushing
what if he takes yeah as i explained
takes knight takes f4
it's crushing why not rotate so again
you guys need to realize something which
is in such positions
i'm not an engine i'm sure the computer
probably has a clear preference maybe f4
is crushing maybe rook a8 is much better
but for all intents and purposes rook a8
is a great move and f4 is a great move
it's just different styles of attacking
you shouldn't think of
every position as having like a very
clear-cut answer
in some positions you really do have
multiple alternatives this is where
style comes in i think someone like
magnus might prefer rook a8 i would
prefer something more direct like f4
why did we trigger that's not quite true
misty mountain yes it is true the bishop
is physically closer to the king but on
the other hand we've opened up a whole
new
angle of attack namely
the discovery against the queen which
after gfknight takes f4 forces white to
lose a tempo
okay gf is played
knight f4 is the response
bishop takes f4 would have also been
very good by the way
it might not be as easy as perhaps some
of you guys think i mean white's king is
still
relatively well protected by the bishop
on f1
we're gonna have to
potentially assemble
more pieces i mean rook f6 comes to mind
as a rook lift and
making making room for the other rook to
come in
yeah i think holding on to this pawn
this pawn is is quite valuable i mean
it's become quite valuable right it
defends the f3 square
it it serves as an anchor point for the
knight i i wouldn't
i wouldn't give this pun up unless there
was a clear mating
sequence
okay
so this is a great example of
where i want to keep the pawn
alive on e4
how
do we do that i mean we have we have
several good moves
you know i love oh yeah i know i i think
i know what we're gonna do
yeah well bishop d5 is the better way to
do it because it keeps the f file open
and this is really advanced but
i've talked about potential energy
before a lot of you would think of
bishop d5 as a bad move and say wait a
second it just isn't it staring at the
pawn well imagine if that pawn ever
moves forward that bishop is going to be
a total beast total beast
let's play bishop d5
i mean i'll show you what i would have
done in a real game i would have played
knight d3 immediately opening up an
attack on the h2 pawn and
just trying to
you know everything breaks loose but
this is a very patient move
bad bishops protect good pawns that too
very good
yeah knight d3 has been phenomenal as
well
so
up next knight d3 is an idea rook f6 is
an excellent move if he plays queen g4
then definitely rook f6 threatening rook
g6 pinning queen to the king thank you
venix prime
uh why not knight h3 another excellent
move although after knight h3 bishop
takes h3
your pieces could get a little bit stuck
on the king's side
could get a little bit stuck on the
king's side
all right
oh and i mean in terms of improvement we
talked earlier about how to improve
without a coach
one thing you could do you're watching
this video
you could finish the analysis and stuff
there we go queen g4 alignment boom
you know you can pause you can set this
up
in your chest.com window just analyze
this with an engine
for 30 minutes check out all of the
moves you want to play see if you can
kind of informally beat the engine see
where your mistakes are
are you sacrificing too early
that's how you
train your mind i think to
to get a sense of how attacks work
yeah i mean he's thinking but
king h1 is forced
okay b4 is panic g6 wins the queen
goodbye
now bishop g2 wouldn't help bishop g2
puts a band-aid over it but it doesn't
help rook g6 and then you win
pawn takes going to keep the knight on
f4
next move is gonna be rook f8 knight d3
it's over
okay four yeah we can ignore it we can
ignore all of this
i like knight d3 this is a little bit
more incisive
and hopefully our bishop is going to get
opened up after bishop takes d3
yeah we're gonna get the rook in to f8
as well take on h2 anything wins
again don't go nuts about like i have to
find the move there everything is
crushing here as long as you
you know play in the right general area
or you get pieces into the attack don't
do anything ridiculous you're gonna
another winning approach queen e7 queen
h4 hitting the h2 pawn with a queen
setting up a potential mate on h2
another excellent move
okay so i'll answer specific questions
about the attack afterward okay it takes
an h2 for sure
then we can pre-move right cafe and i
mean i'm not going to pre-move just
because i don't in the speed run but we
can
and now we're threatening some we can
win in a nice
way you should already be thinking about
taking on f2 and if the bishop moves
away from e3 we almost automatically are
going to play e3 check ourselves
bishop g2 ah
what should we take on f2 with
what should we take on f2 i mean it
doesn't matter but if we want to be
pretty let's stick with the rook
takes knight f2 always nice to meet the
knight
just
ear splittingly powerful attack and it's
easy when you're up a queen you know
it's easy to look good when you're up a
queen
that's that's the bottom line
oh we have a cool mate here
you know what's a cool mate here what
you should see is that
i don't know how to call this like a
replacement sacrifice
the point is that if the queen was on h2
instead of the bishop it would be mate
and so
okay you're like well we need to
move the bishop but if we move it on
this diagonal then we
we bar the paths of the queen so i'm
sure you guys have seen this concept
before bishop g1
and whichever piece is captured the
other piece will defend h2
bishop takes d5 checks c takes d5 notice
how we put that pawn on c6 and it
permanently defended every piece that
was on d5 first the knight took a turn
there now the bishop
all right
knight f3 is played bishop takes c4
again queen h2 mate is a threat
yeah this idea of bishop g1 is not as
uncommon as perhaps you guys think it is
like in the time that he was thinking i
found
three or four examples of exactly this
idea
mate
knight can't capture because of the pin
and just before we go any further just a
simple example just recently found
a pretty recent game actually 2008
strong player with white
queen's gamma boom
e5 black plays knight h5 the decisive
mistake
and now bishop takes h7 rook takes f7
and bishop ga
same concept
where you have two
two pieces defending uh
h7 and the queen's coming in unstoppably
knight knight g5 and now rook h7
queen g6 and rook f1 finishes the attack
so a little bit more complicated but the
same principle okay
great game
okay so c3d5 now
for those circuits i did play the
ponciani in the us championship this
year against brazan
he played knight f6 which is um
excellent uh excellent move and the most
popular move
and after d4 the simplest is e takes d4
then you go e5 eric grows into some
videos on these lines this gets
complicated
but black is totally fine here i mean
theoretically according to theory black
is
totally fine white is the one who has to
be careful to equalize so this is also
something you could consider playing
but if you're an e5 player should study
the panciani you should choose a line
and study it
the line i recommend is d5
okay queen a4 bishop d7
he takes d5 knight d4
takes takes knight f6 yeah so
d4 is already not really a move and i
think i confused something because i
think he takes d4 is just good for black
the main move is bishop c4 defending d5
and now the line goes e4
queen drops back to e2 bishop develops
to d6
white plays d4
now black and castle or play h6
and what i was telling you guys like
after bishop b3
i was analyzing this in preparation for
the buzz on game and very often the move
b5 here is very strong because it takes
the sting out of c4 and essentially
ensures that this pawn is going to
remain quite weak
so
you know don't dismiss this idea
entirely
in any case i don't want to bog
ourselves down too much with the opening
let's get to the fun part d4 e4 we
decided
queen d1 knight takes d5
by the way if the queen goes to g3 this
is
a very typical concept you go bishop d6
anyway
if bishop f4 then knight h5 wins the
bishop and if queen takes g7
i mean
these types of positions are almost
always good for black what should black
do here
and you could throw in rook g6 but let's
leave rook g6 aside for the sec for the
time being
who can tell me um
like the right approach in this position
yeah so queen e7 is exactly right queen
e7 and then castle won resign yeah
and you've got a sort of overwhelming
attack here
all right so queen d1 knight takes d5
bishop c4
yeah so we decided on c6 castles bishop
d6
rookie one f5 the alternate approach
here was to castle
after rook takes c4 we want the queen to
go to h4
so we should deploy the bishop to f5 go
queen h4 this is very similar to a
martial gamut in the real lopez marshall
attack
possible but unnecessary we can just
defend
okay so there are a lot of questions
about f3
two approaches first of all queen h4
looks very strong but even if you castle
look at what this does for our attack we
now have the f file wide open white is
totally undeveloped i mean even after a
simple move like queen f6 look at the
amount of threats that you have on the
king side why there's no way why it's
going to hold this together no way you
don't even have to calculate here it
should be obvious
by looking at this position
that black at the very least is
excellent compensation
okay so queen b3 from that perspective
is a very decent move queen c7
once again bishop takes d5 absolutely no
need to do this no need to do that
because why bog yourself down with these
lines then you have to sack on g3 maybe
this is fine for black i wouldn't have
done that i would have taken on d5 and
simply castled long
preserving just
powerful attacking chances on the king
side
yeah maybe you can take here maybe maybe
you should do this i don't know maybe
the engine will give this line
but you just don't have to
do this something like this right
okay so g3
probably the decisive mistake i would
imagine that h3 is just a much safer
move and black is still better i mean
bishop e6 is excellent for black but at
least white's not going to get
checkmated anytime soon
all right
so g3 and send the questions over as
we're analyzing
bishop b6 defending the night
and setting up ideas of b5
bishop b3 once again in this position f3
bishop takes g3 is simply crushing
everybody should be familiar with this
idea right king f1
and maybe this is not so clear
again maybe this is unnecessary and you
can just castle same thing
and now
in this position bishop takes g3 is
going to be crushing
look at why it's getting wide open
and you could analyze this yourself but
abundance of ideas bishop e3
yeah so castles
maybe position not so clear we could
also cast along but again yeah i mean
yeah sean pinto brings up an interesting
plan maybe white should give up the pawn
on h2 maybe white's in such trouble that
development is more important but i
don't see what else white can do here
white's position is so cramped that okay
congrats knight d2
right i'll gladly take this pawn
and castle once again and the king is
not safe on h1 either even without the
hook it's not safe
should be six
no daniel plays x not really it's going
to take a million years before white
really creates any chances on the
queen side
okay so castle's knight d2 and again f4
a little bit premature although still
winning
still winning
why
well because knight takes c4
and uh sorry no no bishop takes f4 is
what concerned me now you can't take
with a knight and after bishop f494
somehow white is still in the game
white black has to drop the bishop back
maybe knight c5 it's not over
right so it's this it's the sense when
is are these moves premature that's one
of the hardest skills to develop and
stress it's this sense of like
when you have to strike it's not like
gm's are perfect at it far from it
but here i was able to make that
determination
and i decided to start by dislodging the
bishop from c4 so that f4 comes with
greater effect now there's no longer any
ideas connected with giving the piece up
bishop f4 knight f4
right gf4 knight f4
queen d1 bishop d5 comfortably parking
the bishop defending the pawn and the
wrist
the rest is easy right queen g4 rook f6
the game is over
oh yeah so there are questions here yeah
okay so knight h3 chuck first of all
bishop takes h3 bishop takes h2
king h1
bishop takes h3 common mistake right the
bishops are very loose queen h5 and all
of a sudden it's a turn around and white
is winning
you're going to lose one of the pieces
all right don't lose sight of the goal
so here i would play bishop takes h3 but
knight takes c4 and things are getting a
little bit complicated more complicated
than they need to be
knight d3 is a much better execution of
that idea keeps the bishop on e6 nicely
positioned
bishop d3 bishop h2 is just much better
because this bishop is now ready to jump
to d5 with decisive effect
so that would be a very viable
alternative
but we decided on the measured bishop d5
okay queen g4 accelerates white's demise
but
um i'm not sure krish what you're asking
what for who
oh yeah if the queen gets to c2 i mean
first of all you don't even have to
defend e4 but if you wanted to defend it
rook a8 would be the simplest way
patiently bringing another piece into
the game or if you wanted to strike
queen f7 would be a creative move
knight takes c4 queen g6 jack knight
can't cover because the queen is lost
i would play queen f7 queen g6 and then
knight knight d3
and again the specifics are less
important here than the principle
there's going to be a million
alternatives that's not stupid if you go
c4 we just take it it's not dame that's
why we put a pawn on v5 it's one of the
great things about it
well i mean of course you don't want to
move the f rook to the e file because
the f rook is doing a lot so that's a
pretty simple
self self-evident answer i think
um
and that's that's that
the rest is uh the rest is history queen
g forward f6
get this rook somewhere civilized and
win the game
all right we're 12 34 that's a nice
rating
climbing up
[Music]
you